tyler goldstein has a question
do you think we need to make new
research institutions that aren't linked
to academia
and i imagine what he's referring to
is something that weinstein has brought
up in wolfram as well they're not huge
fans of the pure review process or at
least they're not huge fans of only
thinking that work
is worth it if it's gone through the
peer review process
and
well that's associated with academia i'm
curious if you have any thoughts as to
that
well there are things outside of
academia
it's not
arguably most research is done outside
of academia
i mean you know there are a lot of a lot
of research is done inside companies
inside
well a lot of research is done outside
of the peer review process
but overall i think the system is
reasonable
sorry overall you think the system is i
think the system is reasonable
so
uh
you know you can um
say bad things as much as you want about
peer review
but it's better than the alternatives
uh it's better than having no review
um
you can say
uh
maybe mathematical should be more
hierarchical
okay there should be big bosses
who
determine which trms we should be
proving
and then they should
have their smaller bosses who would be
responsible to specific theorems and
they would be the big bosses of other
people who would be proving dilemmas
you could say something like that it
sounds like it sounds ridiculous it
would work just as ridiculously as it
sounds
current system is
you know
given
given the limitations of humans is is
reasonably good i believe there are some
arguments to say that
the what you just outlined is
somewhat like it happens given grant
agencies they have some field that they
fund and so then the research tends to
go toward there so you can view them as
the large boss and i believe lee smullin
makes some arguments saying that that's
why string theory is as large as as it
is even though it shouldn't be because
we haven't seen much success from it and
so on so do you see what you just
outlined as the ridiculous scenario do
you see that as having any bearing to
how it actually is
so
yes of course there is bias
uh
generated by the granting agencies by
the powerful people
be them be them the writing granting
agencies or the editorial boards of
journals
so you know
if you publish if you have a result
uh that somebody on the editorial board
of an excellent journal uh likes you
know that's close to the field of
somebody in the editorial board of an
excellent excellent journal then your
result is much more likely to get
published in this uh excellent journal
and then you're much more likely to get
tenure and then uh
more work will be produced in that field
and you'll advise students who will
produce even more more work on that
field
yes it all exists
uh
but
it's not clear that you can think of a
better alternative
and also
there is still some amount of academic
freedom so the granting agency
uh decides once every five years uh what
my funding will be
in those five years some of my time i do
what is necessary to get my next grant
but some of the time i also do things
that i think are useful that i think are
useful
uh likewise
uh
you know some of my career
is is determined by which journal i
publish in but some is determined by
uh other factors
okay by the results that aren't
published by the lectures that i give in
conferences in china you know
it's much more multi-dimensional
than uh
than just having a boss and the boss is
the granting agency
even the fact that the editorial boards
are different than the review boards of
the granting agencies allows make some
variety
and again what is the alternative
so you know
one stupid alternative would be to say
to allow anyone to say
i am a mathematician
here is my proof that
pi is rational
or that you can
divide you know
here is my proof of the uh goldbach
conjecture
who's arguing with me i'm saying it's a
proof
my my word is as strong as yours
it's much better not to lose control
completely